trovo che onda verde il ricordo più
brutto della mia fantasmi river con
ancora questo mare di capri e altro
quando mia madre mi ha scoperto mentre
drammatico per la prima volta cosa
significhi perdere la testa grande mi è
già cominciato tutto sì sì quella volta
[Musica]
grande tu se v per vendetta viene
proprio da lì ciao ragazzi bentornati a
una nuova puntata di vita buttata il
tema di oggi e adolescenza
anche se a 30 anni io pratico ancora
l'adolescenza più o meno da 16 anni a
questa parte ho pensato che per un tema
così sensibile bisogna sapere la voce
degli adolescenti ad oggi su internet
potete trovarla qui su youtube tra
brevissimo sarà qui di lato a me ed è
lei
benvenuta ciao lo sai che sei tipo alla
sorellina minore che non ho mai avuto
uno che cosa che milano non è vero
comunque prima ha detto la cosa orribile
ha detto che dici la quadra con disabili
è vero è vita io avevo il mio primo
computer te lo ricordi il mac bianco che
è stato il mio ottavo co
a proposito binari
[Musica]
celo celo scusa se ti che rompiamo
abbiati che argomento arrivato fuori
juan che ti rimpiazzava la post lui e
diventa una una c una cometa
poi i punti esclamativi che scomparivano
dal basso la balena vedere il tuo allora
hai visto mai
zack e cody al grand hotel si ok allora
vi pare era l'epoca di gemelli io
giocavo giochi nerd con i miei amici
ranger elfo era in vacanza in sardegna
un'amica mi esce dal bar con una
maglietta e gianluca anni fa
stiamo parlando di quella cosa con e 19
assurdo tipo tipo cunegonda della guardo
facciamo ma che i nomi di no con la
guardia dice è il mio ragazzi cunegonda
voglio che il segno nuovo nome d'arte
cunegonda de già nell oregon da youtube
ora che ci penso a tutti i momenti più
imbarazzanti della mia adolescenza sono
stati legati alla kakà perchè al terzo
superiore cioè andata ai colloqui i
genitori e professori mi è venuto un
attacco di diarrea e non avevo faccio
regno ha menato
restano anche in bagno tipo 2 volte mi
sono pulita con tutto quello che trovavo
il sì in giro tra cui un assorbente no e
che successivamente sono scappato a casa
ma anche sporcato di merda il prater uno
dei wafer nella mia scuola e non ha
fatto nemmeno in tempo ad arrivare a
casa fini sull'affaire boffo
[Risate]
no ho capito quando chiave applicato la
mia domanda è ha sporcato il pater è
normale che cielo sporchi ma ha sporcato
il vate tipo certe può radioterapista
ombrello stavo facendo la doccia col mio
ragazzo mi scappa la trappola di chi li
ancora non era entrato perché sono
spenti la faccia se il momento seguivo
finito è entrato lui ce ne andiamo tutti
sentito la stessa cosa ci aspetta ma
forse è entrato nella doccia è un bacino
e io ho capito un'altra cosa
hpc commentato il ragazzo ci sono
praterie quando si sapeva se avete
capito non passata
premetto che ho 17 anni sono ancora dove
c'è anche la vergogna chimiche
è qui che ancor tanta allora un giorno
d'estate
io i miei amici sposati solo di sera
arriva il momento di immortalare con uno
scatto quella bellissima giornata
assieme a loro e premetto che non ero
andata in bagno da parecchie ore prima
di quell'evento
beh allora ci stringiamo turchi ed io mi
chiedo sulle gambe di un mio amico
allora tempo un secondo e mi perche uno
starnuto così potente da far misura è
completamente la vescica sulle gambe del
povero ragazzo vabbè comunque inutile
dire che ancora oggi quando tira fuori
conoscere
vorrei ricordare io devo dire una cosa
che potrebbe leggere un rito satanico
immolazione di bambine e al demonio e
risultare vorrei farlo anch'io ho capito
la chiami serata tipo che è una cosa
bellissima da trovare una volta nella
vita
ricreazione è seduta su una carta della
posta nel corridoio dimenticato che a
breve avremo del ciclo e che dopo
discipline al senato un'enorme macchia
rossa sono tutta la cattedra
inutile dire che la pista tutta la
scuola ea noi stanchi di pantaloni
noi siamo tutte ragazze in classe da
poco c'è un ragazzo povero e prima
nessuno si faceva problemi a chiedere se
come avevamo assorbente vorrei tipo di
segreto 007 spiccicata al muro che vi
avvicinate accompagnami doveva parlare
di cose veramente accaduto veramente
all'adolescenza io ovviamente tutte le
medie ho seguito un corso di musica
questo significa o troppo un concerto
finale
durante alla fine dei tre anni di questo
corso sul momento più bello durante
tutto l'assorbimento di strumenti
io ho comitato sulle giro e sono svenuto
mi sono svegliata pronto soccorso ma
nessuno brandolino in cadenza molto
spazio e adesso ha mandato questo
telefono la bombi dato sul telefono nel
frattempo più view più evoluto a
prendere
una volta camminavo per strada e un
passante viene verso di me cosa mia
mutande in mano e mi dice scusi scusi a
persone mutande imbarazzantissimo
praticamente è successo che stiamo per
fare la doccia
ho tolto i jeans con tutte le altre
mutande tutte insieme aver fatto la
doccia ha messo le mutande nuove ei
jeans che prima avevo tolto a quindi le
mutande sporche erano rimaste del casinò
e camminando per strada mi erano cadute
si cosa che c'è stato un momento in cui
non credevo proprio facesse a fare una
doccia con i jeans per strada con il
signore che nelle donne non palle cavo
solo una diversamente giovane di 35 anni
ricordo imbarazzante dell'adolescenza
aspetta che sono al lavoro quando andavo
alle scuole mi che durante l'ora di
ginnastica
la maestra ci faceva fare cose atroci
tipo candele metterci a testa in giù
sollevare le gambe
io ero impacciatissimo lo show mai farò
un tubo e niente durante una sessione di
questa di questa lezione certo punto
ottenere lo sforzo di gambe in quelle
posizioni atroce
le fatto rumore qualcosa giu ma non c'è
non è fatto rumore o personale ata ok ok
ma lui adesso sta mandando un messaggio
vocale che ho fatto questa cosa preso il
cellulare ha fatto partire messaggio
vocale ha messo un walkie talkie vicino
papa si è allontanato di tre chilometri
è fatto no non lo dire mamma mia che
credo che stavo la ricetrasmittenti talk
i ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video lei ti ringrazio ancora per
aver preso fatto esperti sugli arti si è
divertita un sacco grazie a te grazie
mille a te niente se se vi è piaciuto
naturalmente iscrivetevi iscrivetevi al
canale suo e niente sono queste cose da
giovani che si fanno adesso su youtube
quello di dire di iscriversi canali
quindi fatelo
ciao ragazzi questo mi fa passato di
moda per sé venuto così senza
non so ma anche spostare passato di moda
sas che non sai cosa no scusami
spiegamelo ogni cosa
la produzione deve dare qualche cosa non
bene usare le vocale la dipingeva un
tipo trap
ok edipo nelle canzoni cominciate fa
dico ok siamo anche utilizzare un banale
ci vediamo il prossimo video non
salutiamo scegliere però magari non
piano allora nome chiudiamolo senza
salutare va bene gare che fai giudicare
l'ex gary che penso che venga dal il
pampa è troppo per me è troppo